autre sujet on revient sur la question
de la tacc de l'attentât contre la
mosquée de bayonne avec ce cette
déclaration qui étaient tenus par le
patron du parti communiste ce matin est
ce que l'argent public versé au front
national sert à acheter des armes à
l'attentât de bayonne c'est un ex
candidat aux cantonales qui était armé
depuis plusieurs années ce n'est pas
nouveau
je demande que les enquêtes les plus
sérieuses soient poussées le
rassemblement national a porté plainte
pour diffamation contre le numéro 1 du
pc alors il reste que le rn a donné des
versions un petit peu différente sur la
façon dont l'assaillante bayonne et deux
parties sont séparés je vous propose à
ce sujet d'abord d'écouter jordan bardet
la nonciature candidat tête de liste aux
élections européennes
honda non cette attaque sans la moindre
réserve
je considère moi que le terrorisme peut
importe la provenance d'ailleurs ses
larmes des lâches
voilà ses larmes des faibles alors ce
type a effectivement fait partie ça a
été soulignée des 8000 candidats que
nous avions lors des élections
départementales et je peux vous assurer
que rien dans son parcours ne pouvait en
l'occurrence l'été présumer qu'il
s'agissait d'un dingue
il a été écarté en 2015 donc à plat les
élections départementales auxquelles il
était candidat par les responsables
locaux du rassemblement national et il
n'est plus adhérent évidemment du
mouvement et je vous propose d'écouter
également la version de nicolas bay le
secrétaire général du parti
cette personne a été aberrante ya
quelques années semble-t-il du
rassemblement national
oui ce sont 1 parmi les 8000 candidats
que nous avons présenté aux élections
départementales
voilà c'est évidemment il est parti du
rassemblement national parce que
semble-t-il il avait des idées qui
étaient là à voir avec les nôtres
voilà cependant été écarté pour d'autres
il est parti quand vous analysez la la
communication du et rennes / 7 /
ensemble cette séquence non mais je vais
pas aller sur le dessus sur le débat de
la communication je trouve que ce débat
est à courte vue
on vit dans un pays il ya un journaliste
dans cette maison qui s'appelle
guillaume perreault qui a écrit un
bouquin pour s'offusquer du fait qu'en
france on peut soutenir un terroriste
qui s'appelle cesare battisti
et dire que ce terroriste
il l'a fait pour pour soutenir des
principes philosophiques très important
il ya un type qui a fait un attentat sur
une mosquée il a été un moment élus du
front national très bien est ce que
c'est de combattre le front national et
la manière dont il aurait pu ruiner
notre pays s'il était passé parce que
sur l'euro ils n'avaient rien compris je
trouve que c'est la hauteur de
l'intelligence française
est-ce que d'aller les attaquer pour le
fait sur le fait de savoir si ce type là
a été un moment encartée au
rassemblement national j'aurais tendance
à vous dire très bien je suis pas
persuadé que la conquête du terrain du
front national petit à petit sur des
sujets très pointus qui mobilise les
gens soit la réponse
après par rapport à leur communication
on leur a lancé ça ils nous ont expliqué
qu'ils hier à la mairie de nanterre
c'était quelqu'un qui était encarté chez
les écolos oui c'est je trouve que c'est
un peu à courte vue d'aller les chercher
là dessus de perdre du temps d'avoir des
gens très bien formés qui sont nos élus
qui vont leur lancée cet argument dans
le débat moi je trouve ça assez
misérable et encore une fois je soutiens
assez peu d'idées du front national mais
sur ce sujet là je trouve que le débat
est en cours confirme reda didi
mouvement oui moi ce qui m'interesse là
dessus si l'effet parfois mathieu de la
parole publique la parole politique de
dévider comporter le front national
moi j'irais pas chercher dans les
dossiers s'il a été à néant tout pas
dans quelle mesure le fond du problème
ne se pose pas là le fond du problème
c'est que je pense que beaucoup de
responsables politiques et de deux
personnes qui ont la capacité à prendre
la parole dans l'espace médiatique et
public ne se rendent pas compte de
l'effet de performatif de leurs deux de
leurs discours un petit peu donner ce
type ce type d'acte donc ce que vous
êtes en train de me dire c'est que les
si je me suis l'effet performatif c'est
quand il ya un discours qui est tenu par
exemple par des responsables du
rassemblement national ça peut conduire
à l'acte qui a été commis à bayonne je
pense que l'effet performatif sur des
sujets et l'a vraisemblablement plutôt
fragile il faudrait vous falloir avoir
le profil détaillé de la personne qui
est passé à l'acte mais oui à un effet à
un effet oui il a un effet dieu moi je
trouve que la réaction unanime et y
compris celle du rassemblement national
était souhaitable est normal absolument
normal mais elle montre aussi que la
france n'a qu'une envie dans ses tripes
dans son très fou c'est l'assimilation
de tous nos compatriotes musulmans c'est
qu'ils fassent partie intégrante du
corps national c'est ça qui exprime la
france le fait que ce soit un
octogénaire est pas tout à fait
peut-être un exotique il appartient et
des générations y avait encore un effet
de relents racistes et c'est donc en
revanche oui bien sûr c'est sait on peut
s'interroger sur le long terme comme
l'avait fait le ministre l'intérieur
avant de partir gérard collomb sur ces
des risques à long terme
on les voit pas trop on n'arrête pas de
crier à la malle gamal amalgame ou
l'amalgamme fort heureusement il ya un
individu déséquilibré de 80 ans qui a
blessé deux personnes c'est un
abominable mais c'est pas c'est pas si
tragique que ça je pense que les
français sont relativement sont même
très très calme alors qu'il y avait ça
ne concerne bien sûr pas du tout tout
pour compatriotes musulmans
c'est une minorité mais une minorité
quand même agissante porte une idéologie
extrêmement agressive et qu'il ya des
abcès de fixation pour le lien avec le
le sujet précédent territoriaux des
quartiers entiers qui sont tenus par des
trafiquants et c'est donc tout ça ce ne
sont pas les mêmes sont pas les mêmes
sujets et peut-être mais ça crée un
cousin sociaux geste c'est très
inquiétant clauzel et dans ce climat
anxiogène
on veut pas dire qu'il y ait des
manifestations très claire de
détestation des musulmans de passage à
l'acte et c est sûr il ya le discours de
rassemblement national
les scores du rassemblement national
mais ils n'appellent pas dieu merci à
porter atteinte physiquement aux
musulmans en revanche ce qui est très
étonnant c on peut se poser la question
à quitte à surprendre un peu sur ce
plateau est ce que si on avait fait feu
à la sortie d'une mosquée est sorti dans
une mosquée à la sortie d'une église
excusez moi merci pour le lapsus
si on effectue à la sortie d'une église
si on avait dégradé d'ailleurs des
églises etc qu'est-ce que s qui aurait
vu cette émotion cette réaction
absolument unanime
bien sûr que non j'ai regardé les
statistiques glisse à l'intérieur on ne
pensait pas quand vous avez vu l'émotion
de l'incendié qui a été créée autour de
l' incendie de notre langue même temps
notre dame c'est la panique les ramènent
on a bien vu qu'il y avait une émotion
que dans tout le pays ouais je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec ça moi je crois
que c'est exactement l'inversé c'est à
dire que il faut ce tag ression doit
être prise extrêmement au sérieux
pourquoi parce qu'elle s'inscrit dans
une vague ou avec pas seulement des
discours politiques mais également la
démission de l'état
ce pays est en train de basculer dans
une guerre civile froide et où on libère
la violence sur beaucoup de plans donc
il ya la violence du terrorisme
islamique
elle est
évidemment présentes et c'est de loin
aujourd'hui la plus dangereuse
on a maintenant également un extrémisme
d'extraire des attentats d'un terrorisme
d'extrême droite
on a des paysans qui se font agresser
maintenant des boucheries qui se font
tailler ou des gens qui font simplement
qu'ils exerçaient d'exercer leur métier
et et qui se font violente et donc la
violence est en train de contaminer ce
pays
elle contamine ce pays pour deux raisons
qui sont des raisons proprement
politique d'abord une démission sur le
discours de la république et le fait qu'
un certain nombre de forces politiques
les ont clairement abandonné et
deuxièmement une incroyable faiblesse de
tout ce qui relève de la sécurité
publique et donc derrière on a quand
même un ministère de l'intérieur qui est
maintenant avec des forces de police et
de gendarmerie qui sont épuisés sous
dotées un ministère qui a les structures
du 19e siècle qui n'a absolument pas été
modernisé et et une sécurité publique
qui ne marchent plus et quand il ya plus
il faut quand même se rappeler que la la
première responsabilité d'un état
démocratique c'est d'assurer la paix
civile et en france on évolue de plus en
plus dans une situation où ce n'est plus
cas on parle dans justement dans la
serre berriane d'une altération
partielle du discernement tous les cas
c'est le premier élément qui émerge des
auditions est-ce que pardon nous poser
la question si clairement est-ce que la
folie peut servir d' excuses comme c'est
souvent le cas aujourd'hui dans les
procès qu'on voit dany moi je
je suis pas mais enfin je sais pas mon
métier est ce que j'exposerai par la
folie si vous voulez de au xviiie siècle
un des fondements d état de droit c'est
que les patrons ne juge pas on ne juge
pas quelqu'un qui n'est pas responsable
de ses actes parce que et ça il faut le
tenir
maintenant ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on est dans des sociétés où on
a beaucoup de gens qui sont dans une
zone grise et qu'il se trouve que à
cause de ses discours à cause de
l'évolution de l'environnement dans ces
gens qui sont dans la zone grise avant
généralement si il faisait du mal à
quelqu'un c'était avant tout à eux mêmes
aujourd'hui il s'attaque aux autres mais
c'est qu'il ya une symétrie yann vite il
mettrait autant je suis absolument
d'accord avec nicolas baverez sur le
fait sur le long terme sur le long terme
et d'ailleurs quand on regarde sur le
très long terme histoire de france on se
rend compte que quiconque cherche à
porter atteinte à l'unité du pays
tôt ou tard fini très très mal il y a eu
vraiment pas en france il y a une espèce
de de fièvre obsidionale de l'unité pas
vraiment l'unité contre l'unité
notamment territoriale est mise en cause
la réaction de la majorité est
extrêmement brutal à tous les stades de
l'histoire donc là je pense que c'est
très inquiétant sur le long terme
en effet mais aujourd'hui on peut pas
dire qu'une manifestation de violence
très forte de la part de dire la
majorité chrétienne ou d'origine
chrétienne
il n'y a pas un terrorisme d'extrême
droite le sang ne coule pas on peut pas
tenir une balance est vraiment d'une
mauvaise voie extrême le dire ça pardon
aujourd'hui là il ya eu deux blessés
graves et tout le monde s'émeut à juste
titre mais enfin globalement on a on n'a
pas une récurrence de ce genre de
phénomène c'est très isolée j'espère que
ça restera isolé d'ailleurs mais c'est
vrai que la puissance des médias
aujourd'hui
et là l'émotion qui est mise toujours
sur les sujets fait que ce soit pour
lubrizol où que ce soit dans ce cas là
la faiblesse qui peut toucher certaines
personnes un moment fait que ce sont des
gens qui vont procéder on sait en terme
de communication par suggestion
émotionnel donc vous parler de la
performativité des discours quand on est
des discours très agressif sur les
musulmans quand on a un nicolas dupont
aignan qui laisse entendre que notre
damas était sans doute peut-être
enflammé par je ne sais trop qui quand
vous avez c'est parce que c'est parce
que des maladresses c'est que le ds ce
sujet de porter atteinte
un certain mélange de la communauté
nationale un espèce d'ensauvagement de
la société également qui fait qu' il ya
un certain nombre d'interdits qui est
intériorisée qui ne sont plus qu il ya
cet effet là et qui a été à développer
notamment par une culture de l'excusé
tout à fait mais en même temps il ya il
ya quand même d'autres fr on vous
indiquer que bien sûr que la la la
société française et la population
française et ses citoyens sont sont plus
où des gens riches clients vraiment ils
le démontrent les gens mais il ya des il
ya des choses insidieux ce qui se passe
dans notre pays tout de même un franc
stratégie vient de sortir une
une étude va sur les questions de
discriminations on sait que quand on a
un nom à consonance maghrébine on a
mille fois moins de chances de passer un
entretien d'embauché que d'autres que
dans les logements fin je veux pas vous
faire tout ce discours là mais tous ses
effets la ccl des effets qui donne si
vous voulez une image et qui ont des
effets sur une partie de la population
de français qui fait qu'une communauté
en fait moi j'ai beaucoup aimé le
discours du premier ministre hier à
l'assemblée nationale qui parlait du
d'une communauté qui doit qui doit faire
sens comme com com comme celui de
mélenchon censé suis là et je pense que
au lieu d'aller à chaque fois vers les
points qui le divise
non mais enfin on sera forcément
d'accord mais il faut aussi qu'on soit
d'accord sur le constat et sur les
effets que peuvent avoir ces situations
là peut-être que l'idéologie
moi je pense qu'il ya une idéologie
d'extrême droite qui est porté par
certains sur notre territoire qui
vous n'avez pas toujours à des attentats
mais qui peuvent dans le cas notamment
qui nous qui nous concerne aujourd'hui à
mener à des violences physiques et à des
gens blessés et qui aurait pu être bien
si le médiator qui est proche du chef de
l'état des autorités publiques dit que
le jean michel2 lancar est plus en
sécurité en seine-saint-denis qui menace
qui ont pu dire non mais je le fais tu
les fais j'ai une règle des discours
absolument intempestives dans la société
avec vous et le fait que cet attentat de
bayonne qui n'accepte pas je rappelle
quand même que le on a eu à
l'antisémitisme n'est plus aujourd'hui
ne peut pas être confondu avec l'extrême
droite et un antisémitisme d'extrême
gauche qui sans doute aujourd'hui
largement majoritaires mais on a quand
même eu pour la première fois depuis des
décennies des manifestations dans paris
avec des gens qui crient mort juif donc
ça si c'est pas il ya quand même des
signaux qui sont donnés donc on a eu des
agressions contre des églises contre des
synagogues contre maintenant une mosquée
il y avait eu des tentatives sur la
mosquée de paris
donc c'est ce climat là qu'il faut
absolument effectivement arrêté et pour
ça il ya l'éducation mais il ya aussi le
travail sur les valeurs et surtout la
remise en route de la sécurité publique
dans ce pays qui n'existe plus on en
reparlera parce que votre constat
justement sur une institution qui datent
du 19e siècle est une organisation qui
datent du 19e siècle est intéressant et
soulève beaucoup de questions selon vous
le rassemblement national at il eu la
bonne réaction après l'attaqué des
mosquées de bayonne c'est la question
que posait sur twitter et vous avez
répondu oui à 54% est assez partagé le
tireur faisait parler lui dans son
village de manière assez problématique
avant son rapprochement avec le rnd
babineau et rédemption qui nous dit le
rn a condamné cette action
si les représentants du parti nous
l'aurait ne l'avait pas fait cela leur
aurait été reproché effectivement on l'a
dit ils l'ont fait tout de suite et avec
vigueur